hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the second match of the finals
of the who you lose bear generation cup
between Magnus Carlsen and Arjun erigasi
we've seen what happened in the first
game Magnus won very convincingly and
now Arjun must strike back if he does
not if Magnus wins this game then the
match is over because Arjun needs to win
this match in order to force tie breaks
as he lost the first one so now what he
has to do is either win or Draw but most
certainly not lose so let's see what
happened in this one if Magnus wins it
he wins the entire thing so Magnus has
the white pieces and he opens with C for
he goes for the English opening night to
F6 with Knight the C3 and the G6 and if
you are watching this game without
watching the previous one I do suggest
you watch the previous one before
heading into this one so Pawn to E4 by
Magnus we have D6 uh D4 and not Bishop
to G7 just transposing into a normal
King's Indian defense with F3 the semish
variation of the king's Indian Castles
by Arjun and Bishop G5 we have C5
striking in the center and Magnus grabs
more space with the D5 so nothing new
here this is all very standard stuff H6
Bishop to E3 E6 and not Magnus plays
Queen to D2 puts pressure on this H6
Pawn but first Arjun captures in the
center captures on D4 on the 5c
characters on D5 and now Knight B to D7
and it seems like Arjun has blundered
the H6 Pawn but this is something that
has probably happened to you numerous
times while facing the king's Indian
defense if you capture then black
replies with the very sneaky Knight
captures on e4 this attacks your queen
so obviously the Knight has to be
captured the problem is after the Knight
is captured you always have to remember
you have played F3 Queen H6 H4 comes
with check and then after the check is
taken care of just Queen captures and H6
and the black solves all of his problems
no more Advantage for white so Magnus
just goes Knight to the H3 he wants to
shift the Knight back to F2 we have A6
by Arjun preparing B5 and now just
Knight to F2 and it's a very very tricky
situation now Bishop characters on H6 is
a threat because you don't have quintage
for check at the end of that line so
Arjun has to deal with this and he could
play King to H7 but he plays H5 instead
and now Magnus plays A4 stopping that B5
expansion and now there is a game where
Knight the E5 was played but here Arjun
plays Rook to B8 hoping to get that B5
moving and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game so Magnus
continues development Bishop E2 we have
Knights the E8 Shifting the Knight over
to C7 to add more support to that B5
push and Magnus castles with knights the
C7 and now Bishop to G5 attacking
Origins Queen checking if he will maybe
play F6 the week in his King structure a
bit more but no he just plays king queen
T8 and now best shook the H6 preparing
to trade off the dark Square Bishops
Bishop characters and H6 Queen captures
it's uh it looks scary inviting the
queen all the way to H6 but you don't
have anything to add to the attack so
the king is very safe here but now Arjun
can strike on the queen side so Pawn to
B5 and now Magnus plays a captures um on
B5 very interesting would be a pawn to
F4 and it's a very hard to deal with
this uh but okay Magnus just straight
captures captures and now he goes to
Rook to A7 again F4 is a very very uh
nasty idea uh sort of inviting B4 then
you bring the knights to D1 and then uh
well uh you have to deal with all of
these E5 E6 ideas uh and also Bishop
captures on H5 uh many tricks are are in
the position and also just F4 F5 and
many scary uh ideas here so okay Magnus
goes to Rook to A7 instead and now we
have Pawn to B4 challenging the knight
uh so Rook captures on c7b captures in
C3 and now Magnus recaptures B captures
and C3 and The Rook the B2 Arjun gets a
very active Square for his Rook uh Rook
to E1 defending the bishop and now Queen
to E5
uh putting pressure on that C3 Pawn so
Magnus just brings the queen back Queen
C1 uh defends the pawn and attacks the
rook and now Rook to B3 adding another
attacker to the pawn here and just
Knight the D1 Magnus nicely defends his
spawn he's up upon so of course uh he's
very very happy uh we have pawned the H4
Arjun starts some sort of an attack on
the king side and now Bishop the C4
forcing The Rook away from the C3 Pawn
Rook back to B8 and now only Now Pawn to
F4 by Magnus and now the queen has to
retreat we have Queen F6 and now Knight
the F2 preparing to shift the Knight
over to G4 and it's not easy to get
control over the uh over the G4 Square
as long as the Knight is on D7 the
bishop has no control over the or over
the square and you could play something
like Knight to B6 but it's not all that
impressive Bishop will come to D3 and
again E5 will come with an attack on the
queen uh so sorry about that uh it that
does not look easy for for Arjun but
okay after Knight F2 we have rooked the
E8 grabbing more control over the E5
square and now Magnus executes it
nonetheless Ponte E5 and now if you
capture here it seems like you can
because you have sufficient control over
the square you don't really because
after d captures an E5 Knight G4 attacks
the queen and covers the E5 square and
once you move the queen F captures and
E5 this is just a spectacular position
for white so so much control the bishop
and C4 spectacular Knight guarding that
F6 square at some lines maybe we'll
capture some D7 removing the defender of
the F6 Square uh just completely blasts
through the position now so after E5
Arjun says I'm not having any of this
just brings the queen back Queen d8
attacks The Rook Rook the C6 now
attacking the D6 spawn and just D
captures an E5 Magnus Now does not
recapture he just plays Pawn to F5 the
bishop is still blocked by the Knight
and now arjun's position uh will uh soon
come under heavy fire and also by
playing F5 Magnum has opened up the path
back to the H6 Square for his Queen so G
captures on F5 and now Queen to H6 and
this is a an incredibly scary position
already some checkmates are being
threatened for example if you play
something like E4 you want to play
Knight to E5 which makes sense of course
this would attack the rook and the
bishop it's a forced Checkmate in three
just Rook G6 check only movies have
characters and G6 and now this
spectacular D6 check from the bishop
there is no square for the black king
you have to put something in between but
Rook E6 is the only move Bishop captures
would be checkmate
uh so after this queen to H6 move we
have Knight to the Fate by Arjun uh
trying to set up some sort of uh defense
here and Magnus just Place Rook to F6
preparing to push D6 and put even more
pressure on that F7 pawn and now look at
arjun's pieces I mean this is this is
just very very sad to look at it's like
that Legendary game between uh vasley
and Chuck and Garrick as part of uh
where he forced all of kasparov's pieces
on the back rank if you haven't seen it
do check it out it's it's a very very
cool game uh but yeah it's hard to find
the move here for Arjun he plays Rook
the B7 at some point The Rook might help
out with the defense of the black king
but Magnus plays Ponte D6 opens up an
attack towards the black king now you
really have to be very very careful
Bishop to E6 blocking the light Square
bishop and here there is uh only one
good move for Magnus but there are many
many ways for for you to actually win
this and the movies Queen to G5 check
and of course uh all of you thought
about this move because why not not but
what comes next is very very important
King the h8 by Arjun and now Magnus has
to decide how to play This and like I
said there are many winning ideas here
he plays Rook to H6 but I will show you
one that's truly spectacular Knight to
G4 absolutely crushing
now uh there's no move you can make here
you can't not capture the Knight and uh
if you capture the Knight then it's just
game over Bishop against control over
this diagonal and now Queen H6 uh will
just be a game over if if the Knight
blocks this you will deliver Checkmate
the bishop covers the H7 square and if
Knight G6 it's possible because you
would very uh happily uh allow something
like Bishop capture spawn capture so The
Rook also gains control of these squares
just Rook e to F1 and now there is no
move whatever you play you're just gonna
get crushed the bishop captures uh will
will end the game now with the Rooks
double ndf file so that's in the
position however Rook the H6 by Magnus
also very nice we have Knights the H7
and now he plays Queen to H5 this just
wins the pawn by force and completely
opens up the black king now Rook
captures on H7 is threatened so you have
to play F6 and now just Bishop captures
and E6 removing the defender of the F5
Pawn Rook captures an E6 and now Queen
captures on F5 still putting pressure on
H7 but attacking that Rook here Rook
captures on D6 and now Rook captures an
H4 and now okay it's equal material but
uh the black king is uh wide in the open
Rook to G7 by Arjun and now Pawn to H3
and the even more problem for Arjun is
that he is down to one minute on the
clock Magnus has some three minutes on
the clock Queen D7 Arjun would very much
enjoy trading Queens as uh well the end
game would be manageable but just Queen
to F3 by Magnus and now we have Queen to
d8
uh he's a preparing F5 to put pressure
on this Rook uh but interestingly F5 was
a possibility even here you try and you
know you give up a little bit of
material for example root captures an E5
now you double up on the G file and it
looks like you are back in the game but
there is this very silly Kink to F1 move
and the black does not have um anything
it's just a very very sad if you play
Rook captures on G2 of course Rook
captures an H7 and that's it if you
capture here then The Rook is unguarded
and if King characters then just Queen
to H5 checking the G8 and rookie 8
forces black to give up the uh the queen
it's a very very
unplayable so Queen to d8 Arjun prepares
F5 and now Magnus just brings another
attacker in Knights the E4 attacks The
Rook on D6 now Arjun plays F5 attacks
the Knight and exposes this uh Queen to
Rook threat and now okay Magnus trades
Knight captures Queen captures and now
Rook captures on E5 uh we have Knights
the G5 attacking the queen and here just
Rook the E8 with Chuck by Magnus and now
what you play do you run do block uh
problem is if King to H7 is just a very
very
um forcing King hunt Queen captures King
H6 Rook the h8 with track Knight stage
seven and now Queen to E6 with check
King G5 now Knights to F5 and you really
don't have um anything uh to look for
here the queen is attacked The Rook is
hanging you you can play some like Queen
to F4 but then H4 with check and now
after King to G for so many awesome
ideas like Knight captures and G7
opening up a discovery uh it's just a
merciless King hunt so after Rook the E8
check Rook the G8 but now Magnus very
very happily trades down captures
captures Queen to D5 with check King to
h8 and now Queen the E5 with check King
G8 and not Knight captures on F5
attacking the queen and just enjoying
his um extra Pawn but also threatening
Checkmate and G 7 and Arjun is is just
finished he tries Knight captures on H3
with check trying to get some sort of a
Perpetual as if he can save the game uh
he continues the match but after
captures here we have Queen to G5 check
Magnus just blocks with Queen to G3 and
now uh it was in this position on move
52 that Arjun erigasi resigned the game
and with it the entire match because
Magnus now leads two to zero and it is
impossible for Arjun to win the second
match in order to force tie breaks so
here of course you will have to trade um
yeah there's nothing you can do if you
move the king you just lose the queen so
captures captures and of course you have
an end game where you are up a pawn in
the night uh that is um uh completely
completely winning
uh so yeah a great showing by Magnus in
the finals Arjun played the spectacular
chess in the preliminaries uh and I mean
throughout the entire year he he just
crushed everyone and in the
preliminaries he only lost I believe the
game to Magnus it was that first game um
uh uh also in the opening they played in
the in the first game in the pits uh but
other than that he just completely
crushed the event uh but now uh in the
finals against Magnus like he said he
couldn't get out of his head that he was
playing against Magnus he couldn't just
focus on playing chess uh uh sort of uh
he came under the influence of the of
the Magnus effect as so many before him
I have done so uh but yeah very very
nicely played by both of them but Magnus
was a little bit better and he wins um
very very cleanly uh he only needed two
games to take the second match in on the
first day he won two and a half to half
and now second day just two to zero so
uh truly truly impressive stuff uh and
other than this winning the event Magnus
also said that he will be giving more
information regarding the the drama that
has shook the core of the Chess World
for the past two weeks uh probably
tomorrow but maybe you know maybe maybe
not tomorrow but he that he will at some
point give us more on the subject so
we'll see what happens uh maybe he does
maybe he doesn't uh who knows what the
uh what the future holds but one very
interesting thing uh that was asked the
Magnus in the in the interview after the
after the match was uh as there is a
soon to be a chess boxing event where uh
Lawrence Trent will be fighting uh
uh I can't remember the name but he will
be fighting someone I know I know the I
know the guys just have a problem
remembering names he's with Eric Hansen
in the chess brass
um uh come on man
yeah I can't seem to remember the name
but there will be a chess boxing match
and
um they've asked Magnus who would be uh
his preferred opponent if he were to uh
to have a chess boxing match to which uh
the witch Magnus replied uh that someone
actually had a beef with him in the past
and that they wanted to fight him not
just over the board but also in person
and that's all the information that he's
going to give so if you know who this
person is do share in the comments as uh
you know no one really knew what he was
talking about maybe they do I maybe just
I didn't know what he was talking about
but obviously he had a beef with someone
so very very interesting uh stuff
um yeah a man yeah of course Amman yeah
I remembered it now yeah uh he uh uh uh
Lauren strand will fight a man in the uh
finals of the of the of the event so it
should be very very interesting will be
I believe in in November or December
something like that but yeah if you know
who Magnus was talking about usher in
the in the comments uh will be very
interesting to know so yeah that's the
game and this short coverage of the
entire us bird generation cup hope you
guys enjoyed it quite um a lot of games
that we've enjoyed uh very nicely played
by everyone and you know I I really
enjoyed these matchups with the younger
players pregnant and irrigation and you
know Vincent kymer and everyone
Christopher you just challenging the the
older generation not just the older like
magnets but older like Vaseline vanchuk
and and bodies girlfriend so really just
a wonderful event uh so yeah that's the
game and the match and the little bit of
extra info I hope you guys enjoyed that
if you have any idea who Magnus was
talking about do share in the comments
uh so we can all enjoy and increase our
vast knowledge I would like to thank um
anhuman Shukla Henry's pragons uh Mr
Robert the crown uh Sarah medrata and
Michael Owens for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day